good morning John this week I did a
thing that doesn't fit well into my
brain I went back to Winter Park High
School a place where I had good times
and bad times but mostly just times like
a lot of times some of my old haunts
were gone covered over in new buildings
but my lunch spot was still there now
covered over in John Green tote bags
this is where I sat every day with my
geek friends doing math homework 15
minutes before class and being happy
that the school was big enough for us to
be beneath the notice of most of the
other groups going back was a deeply
weird experience it wasn't that I had
like one super intense feeling about
this it was that I was just having a lot
of different feelings all at once like
not deep broad I kept looking at places
and remembering two or three different
things that I hadn't thought of in years
like the spot where there used to be a
soda machine that someone had poured
salt water into so that it spat out free
Mountain Dews but also where I once sat
with a girl who I had a crush on while
she carved a peace sign into her ankle
with an x-acto knife this is a massive
place when I was there three grades
2,000 people now over 4,000 people
labyrinthine mile-long hallways no
distinguishing features no wonder I
still have nightmares about wandering
around campus trying to find my
classroom I mean I always knew in my
head that this school had thousands of
students but my head didn't make it as
big as it needs to be to fit all those
people I'm lost now course we'll see
what happens oh this is see lot oh I
know are we all know how long you're
reading books you will occasionally put
real-life places into the end of the
book place where the book place happens
this is the place where that happens for
me the most this parking lot slash
walkway down to where the school is
essentially I found a door that wasn't
quite closed and I wandered the school
proper this is a space built for a lot
of people and there's something uncanny
about seeing it empty like the husk of
some enormous insect that dies every
night and is magically refilled with a
life every weekday at 7:00 a.m. and the
life that fills this place is really
what this place
is like not this empty shell which got
me thinking about what I filled it with
when I was here I mean I was just one of
thousands of students but I kind of wish
I had brought more to this place I think
I did okay but I also remember defining
myself by the people and the things that
I hated rather than what I liked and
thinking that it was cooler to be jaded
than to be careful with other people
some places are not themselves they are
the people that they're filled with
that's not true of everywhere like the
rundown Park by my house that was more a
place for floodwaters to go to than for
people to go to that place was and
remains itself but not this place Winter
Park High School is made of the people
who inhabit it and in that way it
becomes kind of an entirely new place
every three years or so maybe if I
better understood that these walls and
these buildings weren't really the place
but that place was more the people who
inhabited it I would have been a better
steward of that and maybe that's true of
all of the places we inhabit John I'll
see you on Tuesday
do you live in a high school that's
weird man they brought us your book
there I am
I mean I'm using this this is for my
video tomorrow good you cannot use this
you were in band right fertilis I hurt
oh my god this is crazy I wasn't staring
at me right here one time and I got a
bone spur I was like oh wow that sucks I
can't go see John Hank
no well here I